Ooo
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to "Top Bear" oh that started the game, okay, I guess we're going into it
Hey, so you're a flying bear going over the forest and I can oh I-I have no idea AY AY
I'm dumb. DUAMB
Okay, well I didn't know you see how I didn't know you see how that happened you
See yeah, this is me knowing over here and this i-is
Why are there...
<Mark doesn't even know what's happening anymore.>
What are tho-o-ose things?
A- all right hang on -wait.
Everybody back up a step,  I feel like I got... I feel like I got rushed.
I'd like to take my time first. I want to appreciate the adorable bear in there. That's nice.
That is nice. Z to- shoot Z to shoot Z. Ah see, I see now.
Ok now we're on the same page now. I get you okay, alright. Let's do this.
I'm dead, but you know that's just how you start the game.
I guess.
<Mark making shooting sounds>
This bear ain't gonna go nooo-where.
First i- first it starts out with the enviro bear where a bear's driving and now a bear has to fly. Heuh.
Oh... Oh gosh
Oh god. I love bullet-hells so much. I really do. I- I don't know what it is about it
Just um for some- whoa hello, okay?
Whoa hey! Hoo hey! AH Whoa, hey, whoa, hey, whoa
What are doing there are you doing there sonny jim yeah?
Yeah, I- I- don't know- Are they- Wait is this guy throwing
TVs at me? I just noticed that but uh, yeah. I used to play it like endlessly.
When I was when I was a kid
And I was growing up like a lot of the- what I?
Didn't hit that, did I hit that? Did you hit that?- When I was a kid I growing up like a lot of the games in
the early 90s were "SHMUPS" which were
Shhhhmups... I don't remember the anagram of SHMUPS, but its -shoot-'em-ups!
That's what it is and you cuz you go up, and you shoot 'em. makes sense? aww of course
it makes sense and everything I say makes sense. I don't even know what those gift bags- Oh, it's honey!
Oh, I'm a bear
Oh, I'm getting buckets of honey that are flying in the sky, but I haven't been hit yet
So I guess I don't need them or something like that. I don't know
TORPEDO BALLOONS!!!
I don't know what those are all about but I'm trapped in AAGH shouldn't have been there. Shouldn't have been there
Okay, yeah targeting targeting targeting. Oh missed me. douche nozzle. I'm gonna get that honey. Just because I can. Story of my life
Am I right? Okay, so- oh!
Is that like a zombie bear or something? Oh that's dangerous. Okay. Aigh that's bad bad bad
OOOH GOD, O-Okay I could really use a controller for this bad boy because this is the WASD ain't gonna do nothing for me
<Mark Noises>
Come on!
I got reaction times of a Phoenix!
Which I can only assume is VERY fast
Also when I die I come back to haunt you, which is what a Phoenix does right guys? That's right. I don't know what- WOOW
That's curvy *Starts giggling*
Sorry, I got a cur- Oh tracker! Oh, it's my favorite thing about SHMUPS! Its the fact that- it's gone
i guess but alright whatever. Its the fact that they were OAGH. Hey! Whoa whoa whoa that hurt a lot!
I got three hits off of that? That's stupid! you're stupid!
All you bee bastards trying to keep me from mah honey? Oh?
I'm getting cornered. not today. I miss my honey but
I at least I didn't get hit which is a win in my book. Doo-di-le-doo okay. Come 'ere you bahch
What the hell did I get hit twice on that BAAAH honey! Come on get in my mouth!
I've never shouted that really at the top of my lungs before but GET IN MY MOUTH!!! alright. good, more honey
I'll take that. Do I get that? Ooh, honey, and whatever the hell that is I think that's a leg or
Whoa hey, oh, oh mama bear hey mama bear you mad huh you mad mama bear? too bad
I got superpowers apparently. Doo-di-lee-doo-di-lee
*Imitating bear* Arrrrghhhhh
I'm angry or something Oh
Doo-di-lee-doo, do-doo-di-loodle-i-doo. Doo-d-
OW  I got hit, I'm dumb. Ah nah, ah no you sack of shit you think you go
Uh-Oh. You know this is pre this is pre-pretty-pretty tough
I gotta admit pretty tough. It's hard to do precise controls with a keyboard, but Oh, what are you doing over? No?
I'm gonna get that you're not gonna keep it from me cuz I'm great and you're oh no oh no one more hit
EUGH! NOOOOOO
I was right there oh
Damn you to hell oh, aww I gotta start
well I'm gonna do it, but because it's fun but god damn you and your face you big bear
Oh, I got no better insults for a bear
I don't know what really hurts your feelings, so I can't really I can't really just guess. You know. I don't wanna
I'm gonna be cruel about it. I miss that honey, but I didn't need it so oh damn it
Oh, is this a permanent upgrade? Oh, that's nice. That's lovely or maybe when i get hit
That's usually the typical fashion of this, but one of my favorites SHMUPs from 1990 was
uh, Raptor
I don't know if any of you guys have ever played Raptor that was- It's an old game. I probably it's available on Good Old Games
Maybe? I have no idea, but it was great game. Love that game played it so much the upgrade-ability of it
Hey
This was back like there wasn't really a store like Steam didn't exist so when I when my dad got it for me
He had to send in like a letter to the game company and be like "Hey!
send me one of these I saw it in a magazine" like that's how you bought Doom back in the days you just
You just, you basically wrote 'em a letter and millions millions of people do all this- wait what it's randomly generated
Oh, I love that. They're not gonna get me right all right. Oh, that's beautiful. It's a thing of beauty
It's *overemphasizes syllables* Beautiful  it's butterfull it's butter its butter butter in my face-
Alright, come on! come on! come on! Come onnnnn!
My mama bear
You remember I said that you got nothing. That's still true apparently. I got hit whatever it. Don't matter. Hey stop being invincible
That's right. That's right. That's right. That's how you do. That's how you do it. That's how you do
That's how you do- Oh give me that honey. Oh, yeah, oh yeah, Oh you're dead. Oh, you're so dead
This upgrade sure came in handy
Oh I got hit
Ah! No! NOOOO! OH *Profanity* I GOT COCKY!
I- I THOUGHT THERE WAS - AH I GOT COCKY! AHHH
You were dead. I'm an idiot. I could have dodged
Everything there, but I was like
Just a few more hits, Oh I'm an idiot.
*Profanity* you give me the apple stop dangling it in front of my face
Just eat a dick. Trade you that apple for a nice
Dick no. I don't want a dick. I'm saying an apple like I'll give you it
No, you know this that doesn't sound good anyway. I'm gonna shut up while I'm ahead. Oh, I'm not ahead
Okay, whatever. At least it seems to be getting me closer to the boss sooner which is nice
BLALALALALALA
Oh, epic destruction. This game is really cool
Like this game is legitimately cool, I just find it fun
Frustrating, but fun. I coulda had it on the first try, but then I decided to be stupid about my life
Just like it was there for some reason
I went to get the honey
And I got hit on the way, so the honey is actually a net loss- come on come on. Come on come on
Oh, yeah, that's that's a good stuff right there
Oh *imitating bear* Errrghhhhhh I'm angryyyyyyy
Oh nooo, Oh nooo. You're terrible
Errrrrrhhhhggg
All right, let's oh, I can't hit that guy okay
Well that solves that- ow ow why I am such a oh no I'm such a fart. I did it again
god
dammit, I'm
I just kept
Whomping into him cuz I'm dumb. I got this you guys don't think I got this, but I got this these poor birds
You know these birds are just flying along pretty much everything here is just flying along
There's only a few things that actually want to kill me these bees and birds
You know it's trying to live their life, and then I come along
Not good all around not good. No
NO! It was too close! Ah
Please let me live
Please let me actually show that I'm halfway decent at this bullshit alright now bear, lady. Bear lady.
Bear lady come on now
bear lady
rumpus
Rumpus wa-ha-ha the extreme cannons- no don't  be invincible. That's not fair to me. Oh
Yeah, that's the good stuff. Oh, yeah ok you died no, I right into it really. I jump right into it
I'm I'm just a goddamn idiot. No my Wampus. Oh god. If that would have been
NOOOOO!!!
Get dead! Die!! No! Awww come on! AH ITS DEAD! ITS DEAD!!
Son of a tit-winkle. Son of a biscuit Blonker. Son of a Oh am I all-
I'm all the way back at the beginning aren't I it's not even it's not even being nice
So out of a titty-sprinkle I'm gonna get you no no
Well apparently I'm not- If I just fire in a straight line. I should be fine right Oh Wa-Oh
Uh-oh whoa ha nope okay, honey? Ha right bye. See ya, honey didn't need you
Ahhhh I needed that honey
I did I lied when I said, I didn't need it the actual fact what I needed very extremely alright. Oh
Yeah, that's the good stuff. Okay, all right bear all right bear you freaking bear here here we go
We're gonna. Go we're gonna go ahead
Tinseltown bear baby. I got it. I'm gonna take it a tango and you're not gonna like it oh
no um oh, I'm a bear
Grrrr
I'm so scary. Come on, you. Oooh I'm watching like a hawk like the Phoenix
That I am
I rise from the dead every time you think you got rid of me I'm like aha nah, you were wrong
Cuz of how cool I am that's what the what is that that is?
God damn you you know what?
Wow yeah, that's right yeah, that's right yeah, that's right. Oh, nope nah. I'm being stupid
Not again, okay class this is all skill right here watch it watch my skill you guys seeing my ski-oohh hey
How's it going friend? Oh? Yeah? Oh yeah? That's that's that's the opposite of good?
OH NO
AHH
AHHHHHHHHHH
Ah I'm gonna die IM GONNA DIE! NOOOOOOOOO
It's not like I need this upgrade it's not like I need the upgrade obviously I don't
because I'm
Cool and stuff boy they're lucky. Yeah, it's good thing this games fun and feels good
That's the thing about shmups kind of good game. Feel except little look even the keyboard controls. You know it's not that bad
Cuz it's got just the right amount of momentum - it's real smooth experiences to talk about the game for a second
I love the way the shadows play out also this game reminds me a critical annihilation
Just cos same exact style- like the voxel-y. Whatever it is style, speaking of which I haven't played critical annihilation in a while
Oh, I love to play that again. I would love to play one finger death punch again. Oh, it's been so long god
I'd love one finger death punch. Oh god. I got to play that again might do another video of it
Do you guys want to see another video of, of-uh,
One Finger Death Punch? I used to do it like every because it was like my
Go to stress reliever game cuz it was just so mindless, but also it required a lot of mind
And it was a fun. very satisfying like the visceralness of it. That's what that's what I mean by good game
Feel like that is game that is great game feel just because it responds so smoothly. That's beautiful
It's a thing of beauty. I see I got the triple drink treatment this time around
Gonna load this bear up with drinks a surprise a primary like this bears flying this
Blasted drunk. Okay. I got you. I got you
And you got me cuz we are there for each other okay, here we go is where are things good, okay?
I see I see I see that shadow you think I didn't see that shadow, huh?
Yeah, I saw that shadow. Oh, I saw that shadow all right
Your dad your dad. Oh, it's not over oh
There's more. Oh yeah. I love this right this time
I actually got my eye in so I'm gonna actually do not terribly another apple juice. I'm super powerful
I'm so powerful look at me look at me look at a powerful. Eye Schuster. Oh god
Don't even try get out of my way. I love it
I love it the see ah it's so weird and blocky, but alright. Oh, it's so cool
Well the music got a lot more high if I don't know if that's actually gonna pay off for anything, but okay
Cuz I mean, I I mean, I'm not saying the music's bad. I'm just saying I'm not gonna live up to the height
That's a story of my life like I I just don't do that there if there ever is. Hype I'm like
Well, I can't do that if I'm ever up to like win an award. I'm like
Oh my god fuck off of here. I hate that. Oh, that's right. Yeah, so like funny thing about that. I won a golden joystick
which like I've heard of the golden joysticks and
Like it's super cool. I guess but I didn't even know who I just know who do you think that they would be?
Good job there. You should know about that, but again like I just I can't be bothered. I don't give a place
It's not like I'm ungrateful. It's just like oh god. What do I do?
I just I play video games, and I make mediocre videos so
Just give it an award to someone that actually like does something with their life. Whoa whoa
Whoa it's a big cloud. Oh, no. It's a bear, but what is it the whale?
In the ocean oh I
Didn't even see those. I can't see shit
I cannot I couldn't see shit stop spitting at me a white whale it's too shiny for me alright
We got the same colored bullets how am I gonna be able to tell why can't survive another one of those you beam bastard bastard
What if I'm up and left no?
see
What's?
What's not damn? You and oh, is that a bacon?
Ooh
Tiny bullets tiny bullets, I guess that's good is that like a permanent thing permanent alright
It's not as effective. I mean. It's effective more like direct hitting them, but at the same time
I need to dodge. Oh, I think I know what that beam did that beam doesn't damage me
It just makes it hard to see what I'm dodging
That's the problem of this boss is legitimately the challenges you can't really see
Okay, I see what they ups oh
That was just me being bad. I overshot that I meant to go for the the thing but uh then I didn't
See how I sucked all right, okay? I see how you work white whale
And now I'm gonna kick your uh blood. Okay. I'm gonna kick your ass oh no
Oh
God damn it. Why me huh fine then asshole. I'll kick your ass again. Now kick the whales ass sure do love
chicken ass
Okay all the way back and burn up alright. Okay. I'm done just
Alibies okay, so that is top bear I could have done better at that but I
Didn't
See only explanation. Yeah, but this game is awesome. Love it. I love this game. I don't know where it ends
I don't know how many levels there are but it's pretty fun. So I'll leave a link in the description
I believe it's free play it for yourselves. Thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh-Bye!!
*Outro Music*